each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright so start the next session got to
tocs come up versus Kevin uh Bowers I'm
going to be talking about cloudy without
without the chance of data loss almost
misspoke on that implementation so I
guess we'll be seeing lots of source
code do this and actually no source code
but sort of follow-on work to ari's talk
this morning he made everything look
nice and rosy and all happy and problem
is when you get to implementing some of
it there's there's a few more challenges
than you might expect so considering
where we are I'm going to skip right
past the motivation part and jump right
into proofs of retrieve ability so sorry
for the contexts which we just did PDP's
now we're jumping back to pors so try to
try to bear with me so first a little
setup here this is sort of how we think
about the world when we design pors and
hail I mean even some some part foot
raft you've got a user here Alice she's
got a collection of photos and she's
going to just line those up and make one
massive file out of them and for certain
applications we might split this file
into you know uniquely or evenly sized
pieces so I already talked about a proof
of retrieve ability where I can now take
this file I do something coating on it
and I store it in the cloud but what he
what he failed to mention was how do you
do that encoding piece what does that
look like so I'm very going to quickly
walk through what that encoding looks
like so this is an adversarial
adversarial encoding and the reason we
have to worry about the encoding here is
we're going to take this file that we
want to last forever and we're going to
give it to the people we trust the least
so this file needs to be resilient to
anything they can try to do to it so the
first thing we have to do is we actually
have to permute the file we have to
rearrange it and the reason for this is
because the files are so big we can't
compute error correcting information
over the entire thing in one
so we're going to have to do striping
we're going to break it up into pieces
and do it an error correcting code over
that and then take the next piece but if
I just did straight pieces it's easy to
identify where the piece boundaries are
and utilize that structure to break the
file so i actually have to permute the
file before i do my error correcting now
I can do my error correcting over what
is essentially a randomly rearranged
file I can now put the file back in the
original order and this is nice because
now when I go to download it it's
sitting there in the order that I expect
but the error correcting information is
computed over a random ordering and now
to make it even more complicated i have
to actually rearrange and encrypt that
error correcting information and this is
again to hide the structure from the
people who are going to be storing this
file so they can't utilize it and then
we do our pre-computation and encryption
of responses so we take a selection of
blocks compute an aggregation of those
that gets stored at the server and those
get encrypted as well so that's question
so so additionally photos you know any
America and any medication court you'll
work so so you're saying that it's
incorrect if you need two thousand on
the pigmentation asada it just means the
point way to the range so we can use any
error correcting code the problem is
they're all essentially linear codes and
so there's structure that's easily
pulled out of those and so if I just
broke the file up into pieces and did my
correction then I could easily map the
piece here and it's error correcting
information out on the end and I could
just knock out both of those and lose
the whole file essentially what we're
worried about is the adversary the
person we're going to store this file
with being able to take out very small
pieces of the file and yet render the
whole thing unrecoverable you can delete
a large piece of the file but that we
can detect so that's the design of a PR
any large corruption
is detectable but tiny corruptions are
not gone that's that's basically
impossible there's no error correcting
code that can do that anywhere close to
efficiently so we've got to do it in
small pieces and now we've got to hide
where those pieces lie thank you
essentially in addition assuming that
you can order to do that connection on
small blocks how to do including over
budge file exactly without without
letting that structure out in the open
so the first challenge just raises is
okay so what is this what is this
permutation how do i rearrange a file
well it's a pseudo-random permutation
over some medium-sized domain for
whatever that means and specifically the
domain is the number of blocks in our
file so how big is our file that also
implies that we need a variable-length
PRP here problem is the smallest block
ciphers that we know of that we could
build this out of run over 64 bit values
so if we translate that to you know each
bite is a block we're talking about a 16
exabyte file so we're going to have to
do something to to shrink this block
cipher to the domain that we're looking
for there are a couple of techniques for
doing this the first is known as ordinal
sorting so take your numbers pass them
through your PRP get some set of outputs
and then sort those outputs so what
happens here is I've taken my numbers
I've generated their outputs I sort the
outputs into their their rank order and
then what happens here is one map 23
through my PRP but that becomes the
second element in my ordered set so my
mapping is from 1 to 2 and you can
follow that through for the others so
this now this last column here this is
this is the PRP that I could use over a
smaller domain
another option is what's known as psycho
walking so now you pass your numbers or
your input through a PRP and you see
whether or not they land back in the
domain and if they don't you do it again
so being smaller than 64 bits yeah so 64
bits gives you like 16 exabytes we're
looking at files that are Giga two
terabytes probably
so but you're trying to define define a
PR key on a particular so we're trying
to find a PRP what's here I guess
exactly so k is something like 2 to the
30th to to the maybe to two the 40th and
then again this changes depending on
what file were encoding yeah so it's got
to be variable and so here basically if
if you're mapping doesn't land in the
domain you're looking for just map it
again until you get something that does
so ordinal sorting is feasible up to
about 2 to the 25th beyond that memory
requirements just memory in space just
get too expensive to do and cycle
walking so this sort of builds up from 0
a cycle walking sort of works down from
the original size and it's only feasible
to in over 500 so you got your 64 bits
you can sort of think about what that
would look like basically gets you down
to a 32 petabyte file and unfortunately
there's a pretty big gap between the two
and most of the files that we'd be
thinking about probably land in that gap
so the solution turns out to be a
feistel construction and this is very
similar to the work on format based
encryption they use a very similar
construction to do format preserving
encryption excuse me so it'll work for
anything of a power of 2 and then you
can use the cycle walking to get you
down to your exact domain that you're
looking for there is a minimal loss in
security but in the way our PRP actually
gets used there's no attack vector for
that weakness so getting less than
perfect security is acceptable this is
what a 5 stelle construction looks like
for those of you who are interested
basically you take you take your input
you split it into two and you do a bunch
of
e combinations and shifts explained
through look I did get you some
pseudocode and what we found is that
what you can get good enough security
bounds using a six-round implementation
so six splits recombinations / mutes so
that of each in each section here is one
round so if you can do six of those you
get good enough security so yeah so
there is a reduction based on the number
of rounds to the indistinguishability
and you can get acceptable for our
application with six in fact the format
preserving encryption uses even fewer
rounds because they have a slightly
slightly weaker model they they actually
redefine security primitives because
they're not comparing to PR piece yeah
work by Looby and follow-on work by
toggle away I believe it's been a while
the six rounds of providing it is from
but not tanking then for I'm sorry
curtain it was yeah Broadway and also
so yes thank you so the second challenge
with doing PR encoding is that we're
using very large files that aren't going
to fit in memory and the rotational
drives that they're sitting on are
terrible at random access so i can't go
pull out pieces of the file and do my
encoding so i'm going to have to do my
coding incrementally i'm gonna have to
read my data sequentially so if these
are the pieces i need to compute one
error correcting symbol what I'm going
to have to do I can't do that because
only a third of the file fits in memory
so I pull that third into memory using
sequential reading from the disk and I
take some intermediate value in this
case I can just take that one walk as I
read more of the file into memory I pull
in the blocks that I need from there as
well and now I've got some intermediate
value this is some running computation
that's going to let me eventually
compute the error correcting symbol that
I need and lastly I pull in the last one
and complete the computation and then
this can be appended and I've actually
got to do that for every single error
correcting symbol all in one single pass
through the file because otherwise the
efficiency or the the performance
suffers so bad that it's not worth doing
any of this so in fact we you get to the
point where you run out of temporary
storage space on the foot on the on the
server or wherever you're doing your
encoding at about 12 gigabytes if you
have a 12 gigabyte file you've got to
keep so much temporary information to be
able to compute those that you're still
running out of memory on you know some
standard desktop machine with maybe 2
gigs of RAM so that becomes a limit and
then you guys think about doing things
like splitting up your file into 12
gigabyte chunks or whatever so that's
certainly a challenge that we faced in
implementing a proof of retrieve ability
moving on to Hale quick little reminder
was what this looks like you got your
file you've got your encoding you split
that across your three provider
and then you compute some extra
information for your additional
providers and I already talked about
this this morning in a little bit less
detail the concern here again is that
the order you do this stuff matters
matters drastically because again we've
got to read these off of disk so the
first three blocks actually all show up
on the same disk in sequential order so
it's not too bad to compute what's going
to go on providers four and five and in
fact I'm going to do that all the way
down and then I'm actually going to
write that out to disk for all of them
and read in each file separately to
compute these if I were to do it in the
opposite order I would incur all sorts
of random access to disk and basically
it becomes impossible to do in any sort
of realistic time this as it is takes a
couple of minutes for a several gigabyte
file and to do it in the other order
would be on the order of days so now
let's jump lastly to raft and this is
sort of our most recent work and what
you'll notice there's a lot of the
issues we've come across is all based on
this very limited device we're using
rotational drives that's the standard
today solid state is becoming more and
more popular but large data centers use
rotational drives they have a sikh delay
when reading or writing that's on the
order of about four milliseconds they
have limited throughput though it's not
bad and they're they're good at
sequential access so if things are read
in order they do a good job of that they
are absolutely terrible at random access
and all of these limitations are sort of
covered up by several layers of caching
so there's caching that happens on the
drive itself there's caching that
happens in the operating system and
these actually lead to a challenge in in
raft so for example if you were to pull
50 random blocks from a rotational drive
of varying sizes you would see
time to do that that basically follows
these curves and what's happening here
is there are some caching effects to
basically make everything up to 64
kilobytes look exactly the same so the
caching on the drive and in the
operating system and anywhere else the
caching is happening sort of limit the
design choices that we can make so
whether we choose a 512 byte block or 64
kilobyte block isn't going to matter and
that that affects how you can do the
testing for raft so let's jump into the
testing for raft unlike re i'm not going
to give you a little little happy
fraternity and pizza example this is
actually going to be how raft actually
works so for those those of you who
didn't get the analogy this morning here
are the details so again we do some
encoding of the file and we upload this
to our cloud provider the cloud provider
is then going to store that file across
the number of drives and the idea is
each of these drives are independent
independent devices I can address them
independently I can get data back from
them independently so I can specify one
block on each and read those back in one
unit time whatever that unit time is and
in fact I can do this as many times as I
want and I can do it non interactively
so if I take the output that I got back
if I take those blocks I hash them all
together and use that hash to create
some indices for my next block I can do
this in some sort of lockstep protocol
so each round I'm going to pull one
block from each disk compute the next
block I need to go get pull those blocks
again in one time step and sort of can
continue this for as many time steps as
I need and I might have extra time steps
here because I need to account for
network variability or other sources of
variability we'll get into those in just
a minute
the final one the final set of blocks
can then be returned to our user Alice
can check that those are correct and the
other thing that she checks obviously is
the time did they come back quickly
enough and this time is important
because remember we each read takes one
one time time of one if we have fewer
drives than we're promised so now are
you only using three drives whereas we
were promised for if we asked for four
blocks there's got to be a collision on
at least one on the drive so one of the
drives is going to have to do a double
reed and so we can do the first three
reads all in one access one time but
that second drive the drive where the
collision happened is going to take an
additional time step and again we can
magnify this by running this protocol
and lock step over a number of rounds so
obviously now it's taken twice as long
to get these back and even if there's
significant variability in the network
Alice can get these back they'll be
correct but the time will be
unacceptable it will take an well it
will have taken too long even regardless
of network variability because we can
have this extended protocol that goes
through numerous rounds well so let's
talk about sources of variability
because those are going to play a big
role here one source of variability is
the read time from disk so I said disk
access time disk seek time was around
four milliseconds well so then you add
in the time to actually read the data
from the disk and you get a distribution
to look something like this if the disk
head happens to be sitting at the right
spot you can do it very very quickly if
you know your average case you're
somewhere around six and a half seven
milliseconds maybe you have to wait for
a whole disk rotation after you've moved
your disk head in which case you end up
here and this graph actually continues
to go out because there can be Miss
reads and rereads and data that got
remapped on the drive to other locations
in the drive so their whole host of
factors that make this not a perfect
picture
no this is what kasher
so this is yeah this is exactly the
system you would expect it to be running
on and so testing as close as we can to
real world
well so why is that a problem here we
are again back in our our three drive
model where the server has promised us
that our data is being striped across
four drives well with caching it's
possible that they all read at different
rates and in fact I can do a double read
before any before one of my similar
reads finishes and that becomes
problematic because now the server can
cheat by you know maybe he's got to
desktop class drives and one
enterprise-class drive and the odds of
him being able to do that double reed
increased significantly and do it
without being detected so we've done
some tests over drives and then sort of
simulated that out to a full scale
system and what we found is that you
have to increase the number of steps
obviously to detect the cheating and we
sort of get to the point at 17 drives or
at seventeen steps rather I sort of the
the adversaries chance of fooling you
becomes essentially negligible so what's
happening here is what I've graphed is
the difference between the best
adversarial response time over 500 runs
and the worst expected case or correct
server over 500 runs so there's a
distribution for for correct and a
distribution for incorrect and I'm
graphing there they're two closest
points the men on the max and what you
see is if at the point where you get up
to 50 steps in your protocol there's an
87 millisecond separation if we look at
that point in a little more detail this
is the actual distribution you get of
500 runs so you're honest server that's
using five drives will give you this
distribution and you're cheating server
will give you that so at at 50 steps you
have an 87 millisecond gap that you can
play with which is good because there's
other sources of variability like
network latency so these are round trip
pings from
Boston to santa clara most of them fall
in a very very small window but there
are others that you have to account for
and there are a couple of ways you can
think about doing that if you end up in
an interval with very low ping times or
very high ping times rather you can just
rerun the test at a later point you know
if you can test a nearby server so you
know excuse me that your data is being
stored in seattle by amazon and so you
ping microsoft you can get some sense of
what that cross country latency is going
to be and use that or you can just
design enough steps into your protocol
that you can overcome anything you would
happen to see and obviously this is
suspect to how far the data is traveling
so boston to santa clara basically a
cross-country trip if you do you know
within the northeast the you get a very
similar graph but everything's scaled
down and if you do Boston to China you
get again very similar data but expand
it so you're looking at seven or eight
hundred milliseconds round-trip Boston
China and in the Northeast year under
100 almost always so that's all
something you have to design in to your
protocol so jump into the summary pors
is already talked about this morning
lettuce efficiently test whether our
data is being actually stored to do that
you've got to have a PRP that works on
any size domain and building those for
the size of files that we looked at was
non-trivial also that encoding must be
done sequentially the very first version
tried to do random ask access from disk
and that didn't work at all hales then
lets us build our own fault tolerance
into the system so we can take a bunch
of cheap cloud storage providers and
cobble them together into something that
gives us fault tolerance but again
you've got to pay attention to how you
do the encoding if you're going to do
that this is being done on a client
machine that has limited computational
power limited RAM and so the order in
which you do that in
coating can actually make an enormous
difference and then finally raft is
really designed to allow us to test the
data is being stored with fault
tolerance if your cloud provider is
promising you cloud or fault tolerance
how do you actually test that and by
fault tolerance in this case we actually
mean resiliency to drive failures
however drive caching or hard drive
caching restricts our design space the
Sikh times to read data off of a drive
and the variability you see in those
enforces a necessity for a lockstep
protocol that can run multiple rounds
and then you also have to account for
the network variability between you and
whoever you're testing and then
publications we've put out on this stuff
questions
welcome to the content that comes in the
street and you want to sew in a p.o are
your scent we're essentially doing a
single pass read over the file so yeah
if you can keep up with the encoding
then yeah you could do it on a stream
hail actually uses a to pass encoding so
you would have to store some temporary
information to be able to do that and
the raft I actually haven't thought if
you could do it in a stream in case with
raft probably it's it's the encoding is
very similar to a p.o are it's more in
the actual design of the test that you
have account for variability so that you
could probably do in a streaming model
as well
re-enter the I'm sure I'm on how hard
would it be for the provider to actually
chat some toys themselves to the
business signal basically right there
Jim adding some dinners at times the
various locations I mean can you
calculate are you basically assuming
that's outside of that home so that that
is very much within side the threat
model is that the adversary will add
noise will delay responses in order to
to gain an advantage basically I assume
you're talking mostly about raft hear
anything yeah so the primary assumption
there is that we know what class of
drives the storage provider is using so
there's a big difference between desktop
class drives enterprise-class drives and
solid-state drives in terms of their
response characteristics but within a
class the response times are close
enough that you can do the tests
assuming that you are actually getting
the hardware that you're expecting and
you sort of have to go back to an
economical motivation to assume that so
if they're going to promise you desktop
class drives you're going to pay
desktop-class rates and they thus can't
afford to actually have enterprise-class
drives and same going from enterprise to
solid state so if you assume based on
how much you're paying that you know
what sort of drives your data are being
stored on then you can do this
regardless of whether or not they're
adding noise because we have a good
characterization for how those drives
operate yeah so you said you remove the
data using the spare key okay I don't
see why meet computational
nadal can use a pairwise independent
permutation because you encrypt this is
you know you communities correction you
couldn't anyways there is not been
thinking about permutations of these so
I don't see why you think computational
artist there was energy so the reason
you have to permute before you do here
just understanding these computational
hardness in the permutation fairways
right so exactly so that's why that's
why we can go down to a 5 stelle
construction and still achieve the
bounds that we're looking for so you're
right we don't we don't need strict you
know PRP guarantees but we need to be
close enough that we can we can claim
with overwhelming probability the best
an adversary can do ends up being random
corruption and so I can PRP with the
balance ISIL over to the diabetes
and birthday about it instituted as well
nothing so but i don't i don't see my
biotech occupation primitive at that
point you know you commuting and Justice
Breyer cantorial for the community
public generally just the information
therapy device independence almost very
smooth because you put in fact but yeah
actually yeah it's been a couple years I
don't remember the motivation or the
proof that we have behind it but
certainly something we should talk about
all fun that's an interesting thought
because yeah if we could avoid that cost
it makes all sorts of things easier
we had so can you modify and wrap or use
the idea my trap to do by counting and
hard drives a cloud is servicing stuff
now or or alternatively like
fingerprinting humdrums and have enough
detailed measurements particular hard
drives like timing so fingerprinting
would be hard or I'm not sure it's
impossible it's not something we've
looked at in terms of yes yeah in terms
of counting that should be possible you
should be able to design the protocol in
such a way that the counting becomes
feasible it's not something we've done
but certainly an interesting thought
give a sense of providers are concerned
about these types of things like people
being able to count their resources so
the people and this is all my my sense
on this but my assumption would be that
if you're going to advertise multiple
copies then you would be less concerned
about someone actually trying to count
them and you know if that's something
you don't advertise then it does become
an issue if you know especially we get
back to the deduplication question if
I've got a file that's been d duped down
to one hard drive I'm not going to
advertise that to the world so if I have
somebody trying to count count the
number of drives I'm using that could
raise some flags
you want to thank the speaker get okay
so a last talk of the day we got to Tom
rotor talking about dynamic symmetric
searchable encryption to do it thanks so
I work in the extreme computing group
here and I like to say that our job is
to take the bleeding edge and make it
cutting edge and so that's the goal here
on searchable symmetric encryption there
have been a lot of searchable symmetric
encryption protocols out there including
Sony's and others and we came to this
with the idea that we try and make make
basically the product teams that
Microsoft use good crypto and do
interesting things with them so we're
trying to do things that people are
going to use and you're going to be able
to use before i start i should thank my
collaborators so the etherion algorithms
here was jointly done Sonny and in terms
of practical design and implementation
because we've implemented this it's
neuro blankie Karen Easterbrook Larry
joy kevin kane brian LaMacchia and jason
Makai as usual with systems like
projects we have lots of people here so
you've all seen this story about cloud
backup and I don't really need to talk
about this and you've even seen from
sunny the motivation that I really
wanted to give you which is searchable
symmetric encryption so but I'll say it
again so the basic idea in searchable
symmetric encryption is you're storing
your files in the cloud and you want to
be able to search over them some terms
from those files not necessarily to the
words in a document that maybe the
artists and an mp3 file the composer
something that you want to search on in
these documents and the real problem
that's out there is that in a real file
system or in a real email system this
these documents change all the time I'm
modifying my files and the thing that
I've uploaded is no longer correct so I
need some way to update the index that i
uploaded to the cloud and the
implementations only started looking at
this don't support that there's no se
some of them there is no update
supported at all and in others there
there are efficient update operations
but they're not
efficient in terms of their storage so
for instance you have to store say sighs
that's linear in the number of total
number of documents times the total
number of unique words across all
documents so we're going to talk about
two different schemes with efficient
update and efficient both in storage in
terms of computation both ends and
there's two ways we can do this one is
we can update one word at a time so if
you say remove all instances of the word
the' from a document then you need to
remove that from the index and we can do
just that that one word another version
which may seem naively not useful at all
compared to this first version is
suppose I modify a document then maybe
i'm just going to change delete the old
document and upload all the terms for
the new document and i'll explain in a
minute why that might be a valuable way
to see this problem so the basic
overview of what we're going to do is
look at these protocols and that's
probably going to take most of our time
and if we end up having time i'll give
you a brief outline of the security
proofs and then talk about the
implementation that we have in some
performance numbers so as a more
explicit reminder of the encrypted
search problem and how i'm going to
treat it the user has some collection of
documents where each document d here is
what i'm going to call a document
identifier and this isn't just the name
of the document you might want to keep
more information than that I mean might
want to keep say a little you know
140-character Twitter summary of the
documents contents maybe some unique
identify or a timestamp the point is
this is going to be a fixed size
representation of the document so that
when you encrypt it doesn't leak any
information about the document at all
and then the goal and what we're going
to produce and these are all for the
document based one which I'm going to
focus on and described in the protocols
search on some word will return to the
user a set of encrypted document
identifiers the user can then decrypt
them read their summaries and decide
which one they want this is slightly
different than what's any presented
right where you get the documents back
this is more like Bing search right i
searched something i get back a list of
links and then i click and actually go
download the things that I'm looking for
add want to add a document with the word
set delete a document
and then extend index this is something
that will become obvious why this is
important in a second but our indexes
are padded to a particular fixed size to
hide some of this information about the
number of documents number of unique
words and so you need some way to extend
that once you actually run out of space
so the client is going to generate some
of this information send some tokens
from these algorithms over and then get
some results back it's the basic
paradigm now we're basing this on one of
the schemes from the 2006 ccs paper kurt
milagre tomorrow and I'm Starsky and the
main idea in our slightly modified
version of this scheme is that each word
gets mapped to a token i should say i'm
going to say pseudo-random function
sometimes here and i don't really mean
it being a practical cryptographer i
always depend on the kindness of random
Oracle's and so this is going to be some
H max sha256 really my name you dealing
with and tokens then map to some initial
position in cryptid array and each array
each in dec the list entry here points
to another position so one assumption
that we're going to definitely depend on
and all these protocols is a stronger
assumption then as normal which is we're
going to assume an honest but curious
server so we're going to assume the
server is going to follow the protocol
and we're going to assume that instead
they're just trying to learn as much
information as possible maybe there's
some economic argument you can make
about why they don't want to be caught
and maybe you can apply some of these
protocols we heard about today in
parallel to solve that other problem so
here's a modified version of the creek
mall at all scheme there's an index and
there are list entries and the index
then it has a key that's the output of
this function f which is really H max
out 256 on some key on the word and it
points to then a start position of a
list of documents that contain that word
and each list entry at a high level is
the encryption of the next pointer for
the next element in the list under some
key that depends on that word and then
it also has a second component which is
the encryption of the document identify
are under a key known only to the user
generated this so how do you do search
in this context well the user has a word
and they have these keys k ck b kg and
they can then for some key derivation
function with kg generate a key for that
word and then they can construct a token
FK CWF kbw and KW and they can send this
over the server who uses FK CW to look
up in the index the encryption of the
really a masked version of the start
position which they can then unmasked
and point to the first element in the
list and use the decryption function to
walk the list and they get back these
encrypted document identifiers so this
doesn't actually reveal anything about
the documents it simply reveals a count
of the number of documents either sent
back to the user who can then decrypt so
this is really a modified version of
that scheme now the question is how do
we do update no the problem is we need
to change these lists over time we've
changed a document so we need to change
the list of we need to add that document
say if we've added a word to that
document we need to add it to one of the
lists but all the pointers in our lists
are encrypted and you don't really want
to go giving away key KW the key to that
list every time we want to change it
otherwise you'd be reviewing every
document released the count of documents
for that word so instead we're going to
depend on this honest but curious
assumption and choose a particular
implementation for our encryption scheme
which is this simple mask of a stream
cipher effectively so you have a random
value and then the pointers for the
previous value and the next value masked
by F sub kW of our right so suppose you
want to remove X from this list of
pointers that's meant to just be
grouping there's no inner product inner
product nothing this is just bracket
addition yeah yeah so suppose from the
server can get P and n and we'll say an
X so that it knows which one to delete
it's really easy to change this right it
connects or 0 X XOR N and X XOR p 0 and
X or them against that piece since X or
is commutative it changes it under the
encryption and now you've pulled out X
all right so it's a simple trick how
does the server get its hands on p and n
is the real question so to do that we're
going to add a new data structure and
it's basically going to be a mirror
image of the data structure we already
had so our old data structure mapped
words to the documents that contain
those words the new data structure is
going to map documents to the list of
words in that document and it's going to
contain for each word the pointer to the
position of that word in its list and
the pointer to the previous and next
values in the list and a little bit of
bookkeeping information that you can see
in this overly complex specification so
let's look at it in a picture here's the
original list that we saw here's our new
data structure this orange bar is the
deletion the century for this I believe
is we'll see in a second entry in the
list and if so yeah points to X and it
points to the previous value in the next
value it also of course is a list so it
points to the other words in this
document and finally notice that this
deletion entry contains pointers to
previous and next for each word entry so
we have to patch the deletion list
entries when we patch the entries in the
other list too so additionally this
deletion list entry also contains the
deletion a pointer to the deletion list
entry for N and a pointer to deletion
list entry for P so we can patch those
at the same time but all the patching is
done
the simple XOR trick okay so there's
still something missing which is we need
some way to be able to keep track of the
empty space in this padded index went in
the original scheme you generate these
lists and then you just pad the list
with randomness and the problem is that
you need to add something to the list
you need to know which space isn't you
so you can get that space and add it so
the slope the simple and perhaps obvious
solution is to encrypt the list of
entries of free entries I'll encrypt the
free list and this index but we can't
just use the simple encryption that we
used before right remember that forwards
we encrypted them with a key that
depended on that word so if we did that
for the free list and we just had a
single key for the entire free list then
we would give that the server when it
needed some information and it would
decrypt the entire free list and learn
all that information that we were trying
to hide as soon as we added a single
document which would defeat the whole
purpose so instead we have a unique
token that maps to the free list this is
unique lified so it's not really exactly
that and so you can still search on the
real word free list it's some list and
each of the main entries also points to
a unique deletion lyst entry note that
there's a one-to-one mapping between
used main entries and use deletion list
entries because each dilution this
country is set up for one main list
entry so you can also set up a
one-to-one map for the free entries and
you can just keep track of them with a
single list so instead of keeping a
single key we just use some more masks
so the this entry contains a pointer to
the next entry it also contains a
pointer to the current deletion entry
and it's masked by the output of our H
Mac on a new key with its position in
the free list so that means that the
user can dole out just enough free list
tokens they give space as needed for ADD
and this doesn't actually for add and
delete operations so this doesn't
asymptotically change the
kaustav tokens sent over there was
already a constant amount of information
that needed to be sent for each word
that was changed we're simply adding an
extra bit of information that needs to
be sent which is the this distant ask
value now you there's one thing that
does change significantly because of
this though which is that the user now
needs to keep track of the current count
of the free list because otherwise it
won't be able to produce the correct
tokens to decrypt the feelers so this
makes the protocol stateful in some
sense you can still have other users
search and give them their key but if
anyone wants to add they have to
coordinate and they have to keep track
of this bit of information so given all
of that let's see how to add a document
here's the full data structure with main
and deletion or deletion index and our
main index and the user generates a set
of tokens as written at the top here so
as a doc token that is what's going to
be added to the deletion index and it
also gives freelist tokens so that you
can find the free list and move it so
you can get the top entry and then it
provides some templates that are the
filled out partially filled out main and
deletion list entries and it whoops
provides a word token for each word so
you can find the list server can find
the list and then does the patching
trick to put the word on the document on
the front of that list for that word and
deletion is similar so the deletion
token is somewhat simpler all you need
is the document token the dot key and
some free list tokens right so there is
the document token that lets you find
the deletion lyst century and the
nameless entries then for that for that
entry which are part of some word and
they have their own corresponding
deletion list entries
and then you perform patching so given
this entry you have enough in the server
has enough information to patch around
and to patch the deletion the sentries
and patch it out and turn it into a new
free list entry at the top of the free
list so these are all very efficient
operations this is mostly computing a
couple symmetric operations engineering
some Xers so finally index extension
which is trivial given that you filled
up the list or you want to add more
elements to the list as the user you can
encrypt a set of free list entries and
permute them into an array that's just a
block and send it over to the server and
then tell the server okay here's the new
top of the free list and here's the
bottom of the free list of the server
can patch it back in to the old top and
you end up with identically looking
array so that's the document this scheme
the word base scheme is almost identical
so I only need one slide to say it given
what we've said here the only difference
is since you're changing one word at a
time you don't need to keep track of
lists of words for a given document
instead you map in the index just you
keep the key as a key on the document
identifier and the word concatenate it
together and then keep again track of
the XP n values and now the index keys
instead of the positions in the list for
the other deletion list entries and you
can perform exactly the same algorithms
given this structure so why would you
use one of these over the other in
actual practical terms well what does
word based update by you the nice thing
about word based update is the cost of
your tokens is linear in the number of
words that you're changing whereas the
document based scheme the only way to
change a document is to delete the
entire document and then add a new
document with all the terms in it so
this may seem totally useless but the
value of the document base scheme is
that you don't have to keep state on
user's machine except of course for the
small piece of state is the free list so
if you're actually implementing this
scheme when you do doc word based update
you have to keep track of the diffs
every time you modify a file and so
there's a lot more work to be done on
the user side so actually in our
implementation we currently use document
based update okay so I'm going to
briefly touch on the outline but it's
time so I'll briefly touch on the
outline of the security proofs the basic
idea i think was presented by seni which
is you have this fairly large number of
algorithms so generation key generation
and the index generation each of the
trap versions present generates the
token so the trap asks for search trappe
for add track be for delete and then
search and extend index and the
adversary has to distinguish between two
scenarios so one in which it's
interacting with the SSC protocol and
another in which there's a simulator and
it's interacting with this random Oracle
of the simulator actually programs so
I'm only going to show you how to write
the simulator it's really
straightforward the simulator doesn't
have any information so as usual the
simulator just going to make almost
everything up and the only trick is how
the simulator programs the random Oracle
and the one thing I didn't draw in this
diagram is that there's some sort of
leakage so if any already talked about
the query and the access pattern the
query pattern is you're leaking some
unique information about the things that
you're searching and the access pattern
is really which documents that are
retrieved our algorithm of course leaks
somewhat more so it leaks this update
pattern which is it leaks unique
identifiers for every word that you add
for each document and those up those
identifiers is can be correlated to the
the query pattern so you can tell you've
added to something that you've searched
before and it leaks some information
about the free list so it leaks when you
reach the bottom it leaks the tail of
the free list but given this it's
straight
forward to do the simulation so index
generation and index expansion the
simulator generates large random arrays
and keeps track of them the search is
the same as in the original paper but
I'll say it briefly here so what gets
leaked in our version of the search
protocol is the number of results that
you get returned because we actually
returned just unencrypted set of
encryptions for the document identifiers
so what the simulator does is if it
seemed the search before fine it's easy
otherwise it chooses random entries in
the array and chooses a random index
entry and then produces for its token
masks that will first unmask the index
entry to point to its first starting
point of the random entries list entries
it shows and then it programs the random
Oracle like this so suppose it wants to
end up pointing x at a next value n well
it programs the random Oracle says if
you seek the kW which is a random value
I generated and are then generate this
value which is PN X or R prime and then
when the adversary query is there an
immoral for these values it ends up
decrypting just to the pointers that are
necessary similarly add and delete are
straightforward add chooses random
values to AB and doesn't need to program
the random Oracle in any way it just
chooses masks correctly and deletion is
given the unique ideas of the lead words
so it again gets to choose some random
key K sub D and programs the random
Oracle on that Kiesel it decrypts the
deletion list correctly to point to the
random value as it shows so this is this
is these are these are straightforward
if somewhat complex given the data
structures ok so we've implemented this
this is an implementation in C++ over an
intel xeon x64 over when 2008 r2 and
the test here so some of these some of
these results are highly dependent on
the particular distribution of words
that you have because there's some
overhead and say adding a new list
versus adding words to that list or
adding the document as opposed to adding
words of the document so the way we did
this is is something that we hope is
reasonable with respect to normal
distributions of documents which is what
I'm going to call a double zip
distribution so we have as distribution
of ten thousand documents according to
zip and five hundred thousand unique
terms and the way you generate your
pairs is you draw a document from yours
if distribution and then you just draw
words until you add a new word that that
document hasn't had before so what this
basically is doing is writing the
documents on the fly according to the
Zipf distribution and we end up with
250,000 unique document word pairs for
this test we did it 50 times these are
the sample standard deviations is what
the plus minus is so in this case index
generation per document unique document
word pair is eighty eight microseconds
per pair so this is something you can
sit and wait for to finish and if you're
running it on a server in the middle of
the night it wouldn't hardly be
noticeable search per document this is
searching on the largest document in the
Zipf distribution is 3.2 microseconds
per document on the server ad has a dual
cost with that and delete because you
have to generate these tokens so ad has
more cost on the client side because
you're generating templates that get
inserted so it's 38 microseconds on the
client in 2.1 microseconds on the server
and then delete is the flip because
deletion most of the work is done on the
server side but these numbers basically
show that it's it's easily efficient
enough to be used in practice and we
have an implementation built over
windows so this is a straightforward
obvious implementation perhaps but
there's a backup service that runs and
then it has a keen integer and some
indexer that hooks into the windows
indexing service so that anything that
can be indexed by windows just gets the
terms out of that indexer and passes it
into SSE and then
it generates tokens to send to a remote
foreign server maybe it's in the cloud
maybe it's some servers say run by
someone else in your family someone
somewhere across the continent and it
just performs this backup and every time
a file changes the windows index and
service picks up those changes and
passes it to the sse algorithm which can
generate the tokens to get sent over and
do update and so searches can be
performed again across this connection I
mentioned the curt mole at all scheme
this other scheme that we're closely
related to here and is said yet all
which has an update mechanisms the only
other sse scheme i know that has an
update mechanism but their update
mechanism basically has a bit pattern
for each of the documents that's under
an extra encryption so that's what
allows them to do the update as in our
scheme but since they're using this bit
pattern for the documents they have to
have a bit for every document that is
stored on the server and so significant
less efficient in terms of the actual
storage costs so I've shown you a couple
of dynamic assessee algorithms practical
implementation and they support the add
and delete operations that you actually
need and I've shown two different
versions of them which you can then
trade off performance versus leakage
thanks
and to go so you have this long as we're
curious assumption right right hand
there's there's no way to tell the fact
deviation from protocol to run right
basically if if you have a malicious
server they can give you the wrong
results they can what they can't do is
is yeah they can I mean how how are you
using great the schema I don't think
they yeah they can't break the
confidentiality I don't I don't have a
proof for that but I don't think that a
malicious server can break the
confidentiality given that its mass with
random values for keys that it doesn't
know and its unique values because of
the randomness for each of the chosen
masks um what so in terms popinjay what
what assumption would be grown by eating
it's actually it may be the militia
server can learn more about the
distribution so get more leakage from
your system so for instance if they can
send you messages if you're encrypting
email they can send you an email that
says cryptography right and so if you
index this naively then they're going to
learn some information about mobile
maybe this is cryptography alright this
this particular piece
it's our knees began so speed the
tradition to calculate the tax return
shoes
the date of the check organic the excess
better stuff than that sort of thing
who ever said you could I'm jaansma
curious so something is there for
graduates you'll necessarily know
weather widget oh so that's something
it's you could think about scientist at
you you can check availability I mean
you can test that you're getting true
documents back because you could use an
auth encryption scheme busy but but you
can't tell that they're the documents
for that word right because he could
just pick arbitrary document but you can
just that might give you got this
forgiveness this the if you'd agree your
answer you can see that your people take
the documents but you don't know all the
toys in there that keyword where that do
you that's that the other problem yeah
that's the other side of the road really
you would want to excessive Freddie
in either the space one place to be so
basically said that whenever you delete
something to keep an entity is free
industries if i remember correctly right
so when an entry is deleted its space is
returned to the free list so i don't
keep extra information for things that
i've deleted okay so don't give any
point some entity the thing is when
everything is something no the space for
the thing that got deleted is then
returned to the free list to be used for
other things so it just recycles the
space
yeah they're busy getting personal
right please do to support of our
well so yeah I mean give for the
particular and you can work it out right
but the the number so you can see it
takes what would it be like 250 seconds
approximately a little bit less 200
seconds for the encryption of the
particular example that I had generating
the index and then the add and delete
are basically unnoticeable right even
with this distribution you have some
thousands of files but they only take
you know three microseconds each on the
server so it's just not a noticeable
amount of time to do those operations
this good start into slowly um I mean
you'd have to be up at the four add and
delete you'd have to be up at the
hundreds of millions of entries at that
point your network bandwidth is really
is what is what's going to kill you
sending the tokens across is going to be
much much more expensive than than the
actual computation yeah
the integration
that's a thing called speakers